Carissa congratulations a big victory
for you definitely a difficult one
yesterday you had a good position
yesterday but unfortunately you weren't
able to convert that one but finally you
got the full point home and the way the
other important game looks it seems like
you might be the clear leader going into
the final round your thoughts and your
emotions right
now um honestly I didn't take too close
of a look at begum's game game but it
did look like Irena was doing pretty
well so um I mean I'll just let that
play out and mostly I just want to focus
on playing a chess um yesterday I was
like really
disappointed uh for like not being able
to convert that position but I figured
there's uh two rounds left the
tournament's not over yet and today I
just had to bring some good chess which
I think went okay oh you definitely did
bring during that did she surprise you
with her opening Choice playing this uh
peaceful setup with C3 and then
immediately take on E5 or were you happy
uh to see
this um yeah so I was expecting okay I
was totally surprised by Knight bd2
first of all and then there's like this
moment where I was considering whether
or not I should play D5 to stop E4
completely or just go into some sort of
modern um but I figured that
you know D6 is sort of like the
positions that I know best mhm and I'd
probably be able to sort of find a way
through it um yeah I don't really love
this for black honestly like d takes E5
these lines they sort of feel like
White's always uh slightly better with
little to no risk it did feel that way
up until she played a gtes H4 exactly
yes later on in the game yeah so I was
trying to like put some pressure on her
King side and yeah I felt GT H4 was just
uh weakening the dark sares too much and
it really let me um s coordinate my
pieces more I feel and it feels like she
was making moves that uh was attacking
your pieces but it was also helping you
set up uh the best on your pieces on the
best squares in the
position yeah I felt like um Bishop B5
Bishop C4 that sort of sequence of moves
she was running super low on time
already um and yeah I just think Queen
C5 just doesn't really work after uh
Bishop H3 Queen E7 Queen takes F3
White's kind of finished over on the
king side yep yeah and you finished in
style after that with Knight to F4 you
never gave her any chance to get back
into the game tomorrow you will be
facing ruang with everything on the line
the championship is on the line your
strategy tomorrow
um you know I can't say too much because
who knows rang might be watching this
later but um again hopefully I just want
to you know give it my best chess and if
it goes well it'll go well and if it
doesn't then um that's just the best I
could do guys join the conversation what
to say Carissa seriously congratulations
you uh your games with Anna in the past
no draw you guys have been all decisive
games uh thus far and what can I say
just really impressive chess I do have
one question Carisa we were talking
about maybe Anna trying to play kind of
like a mind game with you trying to play
something very equal knowing that you're
going to push you're going to risk you
want to you're going to really try to
win that game would that be your
strategy were you going to really uh
Risk Everything to win this game or
would draw be okay for for
you um um yeah that was definitely
something I was worried about and I
wasn't going to like um I was going to
try my best to sort of keep a
complicated position with lots of pieces
on the board but if she kind of insisted
on you know going to like an equal end
game or something then I would just be
I'll just take the
draw very good your way yes and a big
game tomorrow Carissa uh good luck and
uh we'll be
watching thank you absolutely and